[Music]
mike is with us in st louis hey mike how
are you
i'm good dave how you doing better than
i deserve what's up
well i'm just going to give you a
rundown of
my situation uh
my wife and i are both 35 years old we
make about
125 000 a year combined
we both have great jobs a very stable
income
we no other debt thanks to you
debt-free we have about
80 000 in cash right now in liquid cash
and bank
um
two kids one on the way coming in july
yay uh
yeah so uh
but we since the start of the pandemic
um
actually right before everything shut
down
we bought and sold and then we bought
and sold two more times
since then
how come why'd you do that
well we didn't plan on doing it we just
uh the house that we
uh
first went to after we
sold uh
we just it was one of those cookie
cutter neighborhoods um
next door neighbor ended up having a pit
bull in the backyard and we didn't want
our kids around that
and uh we just kind of saw what the
prices were doing so
we sold it i bought another one through
a friend or
an acquaintance
so the by owner home
but that one was also in another
neighborhood we just weren't
real satisfied with we bought it just
because it was kind of it was cheap
so then we sold and then bought one more
time um now we're where we're at
but we each time obviously we've
gone up and home and uh so the homework
now costs uh four hundred thousand
uh we put ten thousand down on is your
house pilot
house payment is around it's about 2100
okay
what's your question um
well i guess my question is like do we
have too much house um
i feel comfortable with it i know it's
not within your
guidelines right now with where we're at
but i feel like we can grow actually it
should be
i mean we tell people not to have a
house payment more than a fourth of
their take-home pay
and your take-home pay i mean not
counting retirement coming out or health
insurance coming out but take home pay
after taxes and your take-home pay ought
to be
nine grand
anyway it's about seven
seventy five hundred because uh i'm a
teacher so i get
i get a lot taken out for my pension but
that's not what i'm talking about i'm
talking about your take-home pay after
taxes not out after take-home pay with
your pension
or take home pay for your 401k or take
home pay for your health insurance
that's not we don't count that i'm
talking about your gross minus your
taxes
shouldn't be more than a fourth of that
now did you put this on a 15-year
fixed we did not it's on a 30 which i
know it's not the best but no it's all
30 on on three percent yeah and you need
to get so you need to work to get it
paid off as soon as you can but no
you're not you're not in over your head
on house i'll tell you what you are
doing
impulsing houses
is straight up stupid
these three moves
very expensive
very expensive i mean and so
if you're gonna buy a house
we find out what's in the backyard of
the next door neighbor before we buy
the house if you're gonna buy a house
you you there's a permanence
to that that you have to consider all
the possible variables
you can't just go out for the weekend
and come home with a new house yeah i'd
be willing to bet there's some anxiety
issues there's some marriage there's
something going on there's some running
happening just ping-ponging back and
forth and being in house number three
and already thinking well maybe i should
uh let's
somebody is also not going to make you
happy no it will not
in fact
make you sad and so what you need to do
is you need to sit your butt in that
house and not move again
for a long time and then when you feel
uncomfortable you feel that itch you
feel the things starting to rattle deal
with that
don't figure out what's causing the
rattle not the thing yes so
yeah you're you're you're jumping around
man i mean you impulsing houses
whoo it'll get you and here and
especially in this kind of market dave
i've had this in the new book i've been
there like you've impulsed houses i've
impulsed yeah man and it and it was
covering up
an internal thing that i was just the
machine was saying run run run run run
oh and you were sure you're running i'm
running from this rental house to that
rental house to this bought this house
sold this house moved me and my wife to
a residence hall on a college campus
trying to just try just frantic to do a
thing without getting to the court
issues so i've been down that road
before yeah somebody that's running